[Musique]
wilson
et vous sa chérie
est ce que tu fais là ah pardon mon
amour maintenant j'ai fait n'est plus de
travail je me suis dit on aurait pu
faire un p'tit ciné ouais super bonne
idée
et bein euh tu me laisses le quoi et des
meilleurs en gros tu minutes 10 minutes
grand match un bon mahdi minutes
donc vous voulez pardon j'aurais dû
prévenir c'est ma faute maintenant c'est
un problème bat stéphane marc marc ses
fans à eybens salut salut
ouais bon choix de te rencontrer depuis
ce temps ben pareil ouais c'est cool ben
je vais en profiter pour passer voir
réaliser nous les concevoir
il faut encore ça ça vient ça y est
cette histoire au nom spurs jouent à
beaujeu fils rené mise à la tout mauvais
c'est mon gars
[Musique]
ah bah oui pardon pour le retard on
était sûr planning des vacances c'est
une vraie galère et entre marqué ces
deux nanas stéphane et son mec enfin bon
je te raconte pas des coûts et du coup
on loue une baraque tout se recentrait
la rochelle comme ça bouffe pas dans
merde
ces pratiques at on pas dangereux aussi
d'ailleurs ah cool bon eh toi et ben
demain soir je dîne enfants avec nico tu
sais mon collègue bola ah oui si tu
dragues depuis des semaines mais de
façon lourde est nul à chier
bah oui mais bon moi j'en fais des
caisses quand je suis nerveuse c'est
comme ça je sais pas je me supporte même
et baguettes la tomate à makatea salut
salut
bah du coup thomas katia qu on chantait
non je vois qu'on a les mêmes goûts et
brunstatt et gourde assieds toi oui j'en
arrive et ça qu'est ce que je veux c'est
votre pétillante c'est un bon cru je
remets témoin la même chose une bière
simple et un blanc sec très efficace
simple
aimable vous connaissez ce bout là la
femme moderne
non mais sérieux sérieux quoi on a fait
des études ça va je peux qu être dans la
vie je vis principalement par
procuration en regardant des séries où
les gens ont des vies beaucoup plus
palpitante que la mienne j'élève un chat
aussi qui obèses donc ça prend beaucoup
de temps et maintenant j'ai une vie
somme toute un peu beauf et toi je suis
attachée de presse dans une maison
d'édition à ses coûts donc tu gères
l'image des livres oui exactement
donc tes collègues c'est des bouts de
papier c'est pas trop chiant non mais la
machine à café ça doit être quand même
gonflante parler avec des bouts de
papier empilés les uns sur les autres
avec des mots dessus tu as déjà un
bouquin qui t'a fait un gros scandale ou
qui agit un peu comme une diva genre
ouais moi je veux une douche dans ma
loge hors de question que je croise
guerre et paix - les grands classiques
ça me non
cet accord une phrase c'est bien de
faire cette blague c'est beaucoup cette
blague ouais ouais encore je n'ai pas
fait la blague du pingouin qui respire
par le cul [ __ ] de toi de me plaire
mais là c'est parti d'un coup dommage
dommage
[Musique]
on n'a qu'à faire du feu doux enjoy
c'est super à ce que tu fais c'est
génial
la table un peu tous revenir ici sur
l'école et du comme j'en voyais passer
la corbeille de fruits là c'était la
corbeille de fruits de la grand merci
ça c'est un peu moi c'est un le dit pas
plus ah oui si tu veux
au littoral moyens dans la blogosphère
n'est pas tout le temps mais il s'ennuie
pas s'ennuyer
chez toi comment pendant ses blagues
[Musique]
c'est la ligne je savais que ce serait
super excitant le plan de travail
qu'est-ce qu'on est bon qu'est-ce que je
me gèle le culte à passer du marbre mais
ça me gène le pion par contre moi
j'étais pas hyper concentré je te le
dire j'étais pas au top du top
abou mais ce soir je vous parle ce soir
je vois ni comme mon collègue et si je
te parler de lui c'est celui qui perd
beau et que j'essaie de draguer depuis
des semaines mais je sais pas s'il est
juste complètement con ou s'ils voient
pas mais signaux pourtant la semaine
derrière je vais envoyer un nude hyper
sexy j'ai écrit aux pardons le mauvais
destinataire et il m'a répondu lol donc
je sais pas trop ce qu'on fuit
je peux jouer ou je te plait pas t'en
penses quoi
j'ai franchement je sais pas trop non
parce que je sais que je suis pas la
meilleure à ce à quoi je sais pas il est
trop beau un avis est trop beau pour moi
il est stocks si tel est mon stock on
dirait une montagne de faire deux fois
moins en largeur quasiment et les grande
saveur soldes sont bizarres léger les
bulldogs ont tous entendu tu veux aller
aux toilettes je peux mettre de la
musique stu danger vos mesures c'est un
truc que tu as mangé chez pas le saumon
ah non
maintenant le saumon je les mange et
aussi et moi ça va à la quiche n'a pas
mangé une quiche awassa voilà tu vas pas
falaises de tout ce qu'on a fait depuis
deux jours moi je comprends pas ce que
j'ai faugère
même enseigne
c'est sûr que c'est pas le saumon
[Musique]
m